Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie have been
in the middle of a custody battle for
quite some time now and there is a new
development et has obtained documents
showing that a trial date has been set
for December 4th so here's what we know
of course Brad and Angelina the news
broke that they had split in 2016
that's how long things have been going
on but the court documents that we've
obtained were filed on Monday here they
are and basically what we know again a
trial date now set for December 4th
there's been so much back and forth
between the two ups and downs in terms
of how they feel about each other and
the situation of their custody battle
what the documents say is that they want
to extend the appointment of a judge
who's on the case right now they want to
extend him as a temporary judge I'm
sorry him or her through June 30th of
2019 and this judge will hear and
determine all pretrial issues requests
and motions in the case and also preside
over the trial now at the judges
discretion Brad and Angie may be able to
appear at the trial via phone they're
not exactly sure where it will be yet of
course these two have very busy filming
schedules with their different projects
that they work on when they were
together they used to travel back and
forth to each other's movie sets but now
it's become more of an issue because
there's been some contention between the
two and where will the kids be and with
who and what country it's all got to get
figured out so it is expected that the
courtroom will be sealed off to anyone
other than the parties involved which is
fairly standard in custody cases and
again things had been tense in the past
but in August a source close to the
situation did tell et that the two had
reached an interim agreement at the time
so Brad and Angie moving forward Brad
had wanted more joint legal and physical
custody of the kids so we will see what
happens
trying to co-parent and keep things
amicable we'll keep you guys posted
[Music]
[Applause]